military attack on the island?
There's genuine concern there.
Is beijing in your view,
threatening Taiwan with war. Yes
indeed. Look at the military
sizes, exercises and also their
rhetoric. There seems to be
trying to get ready to launch a
war against Taiwan. But if we
look at the U. N charter, the
most fundamental T net in
resolving international dispute
should be through peaceful means
and beijing's way of channeling
the differences between Taiwan
and China is through coercion,
military threat and the threat
to use force against Taiwan and
these are all acceptable and
therefore the Taiwanese
government. Look at the Chinese
military trip, something that
cannot be accepted and we
condemned it. Does Taiwan have
today what it needs to defend
itself. Yes we do. We have been
a procuring military arsenals
from the United States for a
long time in when president
Biden was in office. All these
years they have announced a
night badges of arms sale to
Taiwan, and we have also been
increasing our military
training. So that we are ready
at any moment if China wants to
launch a war against Taiwan, and
I think in in in a war situation
the determination is probably
more important than the military
equipment and this is also going
to impact economically the rest
of the world and therefore the
international community,
especially democracies should
tell China to stop threatening
war and to stop preparing for
war against Taiwan. These
exercises, of course, followed
the visit of the Taiwanese
president of the U. S, including
meetings. Among them with the
house speaker Kevin Mccarthy. Is
there any regret. Is it your
view your concern that the costs
were too high? No the president
of Taiwan where there is
president Lee president Chen
president marwood now, president
. Hi we're being visiting our
diplomatic allies in Latin
America, uh, and with transits
through the United States, and
it's been going on for decades,
and therefore China should not
make any exception out of these
transit through the united
States. China cannot dictate how
tight a one make friends. And
China cannot dictate how our
friends I want to show support
to Taiwan. You mentioned, uh,
outside support for Taiwan's
defense more than once.
President Biden has said that
the us will defend Taiwan
militarily if China were to
attack. As you know, oftentimes
, his advisers will then say
that the U. S policy has not
changed. But then the president
will say it again. The U. S will
defend Taiwan militarily does
Taiwan believed that the us
would come to Taiwan's defense
militarily if China were to
invade. Well, there are
different things, uh, the united
States can do in any event of
the Chinese military attack
against Taiwan, but we have also
made it very clear defending
Taiwan is our own
responsibility. It's our
freedom. And it's our democratic
way of life and it's all
sovereignty and we want to
defend ourselves. And what we
see is that the United States
seems to be more determined than
ever in the creating a situation
that China would know that is
military attack against Taiwan
is going to be associated with a
heavy cost, and we appreciate
the United States for having
this posture. Before we go.
There are differing assessments
of when China might make an
attempt to attack Taiwan
militarily. There's a us general
who made quite some headlines
several weeks ago when he said,
be prepared by 2025. There have
been intelligence assessments
that China might try by 2027, or
at least that she has told his
military to be ready by then.
From Taiwan's point of view. Has
it become a question not of if
but of when China might take
military action. Ah it is our
perspective that China may use
force against Taiwan. But if we
learned what China has learned
over the years is that they want
to use military force at the
time when they have to, but
sometimes they want to, uh,
crossed the enemies without the
actual use of force, and we are
seeing different kinds of
perspectives being in discussion
here in Taiwan, but normally the
when China is going to use this
military force against Taiwan.
Taiwan needs to be prepared. If
China sees that Taiwan is
prepared Taiwan has adequate
depends capabilities ensure that
Chinese leaders will think twice
before they decide to use force
against Taiwan and no matter
where it is 2025 or 2027, or
even beyond Taiwan simply needs
to get ready. I also asked the
foreign minister about comments
from the French president
Emmanuel macron over this
weekend after meeting with the
Chinese president's in which he
seemed to suggest that France
didn't want to get involved in
the Taiwan flap come out on the
side of the us here and now,
French officials have since said
those comments were
misinterpreted. But I asked the
foreign minister how Taiwan
interpreted that comment and
they say they've reached out to
the French government to get
clarity to see exactly what he